hey everybody i'm off the grid for  august but the biden administration  still sucks  we know that we really are quite behind  in terms of maximizing our collective  understanding about how we will engage  on the technology of today and what we  can quickly and easily predict will be  the technology over the next decades  so to maintain our position as the  united states of america on this issue  it is critical that we work together to  understand where we are  to recognize and have the courage to  speak truth about what is obsolete  and then to partner to ensure that we  are speaking the same language  with the same motivation  inspired  by the opportunity of it all  but then doing the work of updating  how we've been talking and thinking  about  our exploration in space